so I bought the limited edition Super
Mario cookies from Oreo and they are so
cute that I don't know if I want to eat
them before I show you the individual
cookies I did get this letter from Mario
Princess Peach is missing Bowser is
trying to take over her castle you're
one of the first people to receive our
Super Mario Oreo cookie packs so we need
you to lead fans in a cookie challenge
to defeat Bowser basically they're
asking me to advertise which wow great
thank you here I am I guess
let's open them oh my God we've got toad
Bowser y'all she's so cute looks like
Koopa piranha plant oh my gosh there are
so many this one's just a coin
I'm gonna eat Bowser because it seems
like the right thing to do
tastes like Arya